повстання канцлер фрг ангела Меркель і
президент Росії Володимир Путін
були прямо ванною вічно, адже щось
конфлікту на сході України 3 і більше
року тому в парижі вже загинула від шиви
наші мінські домовленості
пробуксовувати рік тому канцлер до
овалу сила праведного ні пара горе
прибрали не ще правда black їх
викарбуваних не покладаючи на це
надрукований став кидатися пророню оцінку
ситуації так ми перебуваємо в даний момент
я б сказала ми не за ви не дуже кувата
адже зустрічі завтра ж у дружини
спокійному на сході України лютому 2015
уроку став вся прогрес президенту
Франції концерті ними джини вдалося
assist та розум застиг поговоривши з
українським президентом порошенка та
путіним і пити висота мінську воду і нго
функцій порно зрілі всі проблиск nadie
ми були схожі на комплекс на реалізацію
мінська allows its ще травня ніби
реалізовано там я дивлюся особі даним
what all assets та відео танкових
порушувати Петро їм він їх росію
сепаратистів їжу eeprom про вас them with
в це не вискнув давно привід дружину
алла бюджетного прориву в'язницю на плівку
німа друга т маяку меркель хочеш
поговорити з путіним з сировини
помер якщо так вже на моя ілюзія ще до
результативності цик пари горіа і на
провідницю зустрічі вона нагадала ще
інструмент санкцій чим можна буде і за
стуса ванною і всім у харчування